10 Signs and Symptoms of Hypersexual Disorder
What is Hypersexual Disorder?
According to a proposed definition for the DSMV,
it's defined as, "a sexual desire disorder,
with an impulsivity component".
In 2010, the American Psychiatric Association
released a draft of symptoms that may define sex addiction,
formerly known as Hypersexual Disorder.
Number one: excessive masturbation.
Excessive masturbation is one of the most common early sex addiction signs.
Psych Central reports that it's about how you're living your life instead of how often you masturbate.
As long as the masturbation remains simply a part of your life, and does not take over daily activities,
then you don't have a problem.
People with Hypersexual Disorder often masturbate to escape problems in their lives or relationships
and they usually masturbate during other sexual activity,
like viewing pornography, or talking to a phone sex operator.
2: Obsession with sex.
Hyspersexual Disorder causes its patients to become obsessed with sex
to the point that it takes over their lives.
They spend an extraordinary amount of time fantasising about their sexual urges,
and engaging in sexual behaviour.
Doctor Steven J Seay, a clinical psychologist in the U.S.,
explains that sexual obsessions are very common
in people suffering from Obsessive Compulsive Disorder (OCD).
These sexual obsessions involve; unwanted thoughts,
ideas, impulses, or images focussing on sexual content.
While individuals with Hypersexual Disorder
feel guilt, shame, hopelessness, and depression,
individuals with OCD and sexual symptoms
see themselves as disgusting, deviant, or evil.
3. Excessive time planning sexual activity.
Just like drug addicts, sex addicts will spend a lot of time
figuring out where and how they will get their next fix.
As Hypersexual Disorders puts it,
"this can also become harmful if it takes over other aspects of their lives.
For example, addicts usually prioritise planning sexual activity over work or personal relationships."
4. Frequent viewing of pornography.
Whether it's videos, adult magazines, websites, chat rooms, or webcams,
people with Hypersexual Disorder view pornography in a variety of ways.
They may also use dating websites to connect with others who are interested in sexual relationships.
It is important to note, however, that porn addiction is not the same as sex addiction.
Porn addiction is a type of sex addiction,
but it has its own causes and symptoms,
independent from sex addiction.
According to PsychGuides.com
porn addiction is not yet an official diagnosis in the DSMV,
but it can lead to serious consequences.
5. Frequent use of phone sex services.
Similar to pornography,
sex addicts will often turn to phone sex services to satisfy their needs.
This is because phone sex provides addicts with some form of human contact,
taking it a step further than masturbation and pornography.
The use of phone sex services can sometimes escalate into hiring prostitutes,
reckless sexual activity,
substance abuse during sexual activity,
sexual agression, or
dangerous sexual behaviour, like autoerotic asphyxiation.
6. Having multiple sex partners and frequent one-night stands.
In order to remain satisfied,
sex addicts often have multiple sex partners
and have frequent one-night stands.
This can be problematic,
as studies have shown that there is a correlation between the number of sex partners, and
one's mental health.
Interestingly, researchers have found that the chances of developing substance dependance
increased with the number of sex partners that participants had.
This correlational relationship was particularly stronger in women.
However, the researchers also noted that
casual relationships usually stemmed from lack of emotional fulfilment.
Thus, people in these relationships may turn to substance abuse to self-medicate.
7. Staying emotionally detached from sexual partners.
Sex addicts are unable to establish and maintain
normal, healthy connections with their partners.
So they often avoid becoming emotionally attached to their sexual partners.
A survey done of more than one thousand people in 2013
showed that having an emotional connection makes better sex.
However, sex addicts lack the emotional intimacy and vulnerability
that is needed to develop a real connection,
so they often have mindless, meaningless, emotionless sex with their sexual partners.
8. Engaging in sexual behaviour that directly conflicts with personal values.
The McKinley Health Centre states that it is extremely
important to know what your sexual values are.
Which may not match those of your parents, religion, or culture.
For sex addicts, this causes a strong internal conflict.
While some sex addicts may be devoutly religious,
they will still find it hard to stop and resist
sexual activity because they are highly addicted.
This causes a cycle where they cannot stop,
but continue to engage in sexual activity to fulfil their needs.
They might even progress into having multiple partners or extramarital partners,
frequent one-night stands, and sex with prostitutes.
9. Frequently engaging in paraphilias
Sex addicts often engage in paraphilias,
which are sexual behaviours that are considered unusual or unacceptable.
These include, exhibitionism, voyeurism, sadism,
masochism, and pedophilia.
Exhibitionism involves exposing one's genitals or sexual organs to a stranger, according to Psychology Today.
Voyeurism involves having sexual fantasies, urges, or behaviours
regarding the act of observing a person who is naked,
getting undressed, or engaging in sexual activities.
Voyeurism became formerly known as Voyeuristic Disorder in the DSMIV
Sadomasochism is sexual activity in which one person enjoys inflicting pain on another person,
who derives pleasure from experiencing pain.
Lastly, pedophilia is when one experiences sexual feelings towards children.
10. Inability to stop
One of the primary signs of a sex addict is
an inability to stop despite the consequences.
These consequences may be financial, social, health,
or emotionally related.
For example, being addicted to sex could begin to affect performance at work,
which could result in unemployment.
Being addicted to sex is also a costly addiction
because addicts spend on sex through prostitution,
online sex services, like sexual fantasy chatrooms,
or phone sex services.
In terms of health consequences,
sex addicts' promiscuity can lead to unwanted pregnancy or STDs
Hypersexual Disorder or sex addiction is a serious disorder
that affects nearly 12 million people in the United States
This number is increasing due to the availability of sexual material online,
as well as the increase in sexual chat rooms and web time services.
If you're suffering from Hypersexual Disorder,
or if you know someone who is,
try to find a Sex Addicts Anonymous group nearby or visit sexhelp.com
to find a certified therapist near you.
Leave a like and a comment if you found this information informative
and we'll see you in the next video!